There are a number of new members of the House
of Representatives who really should already
resign or be impeached.
And at the very top of that list of that list
is Congresswoman Lauren Bobert.
Some people are calling her Bobo the clown
that we're not doing that.
But there are people who are doing that.
Her name is Lauren Bobert.
She is one of the people who objected to having
to go through a metal detector to get onto
the House floor.
She wants to be armed on the House floor,
yadda, yadda, yadda.
OK, that's the person I'm talking about.
And allegations have been swirling that she
may have been complicit in the riotous pro
Trump insurrection on January 6th by having
given tours to the eventual radical insurrectionists
of the Capitol building in the lead up to
the January 6th riots.
Now, we already heard, for example, from Congressman
James Clyburn, who said, listen, I have a
marked office and I also have an unmarked
office where I work as majority whip or whip.
As Frank Underwood would say, somehow they
knew to go right to my unmarked office.
That's weird.
And on the other side of this puzzle are the
allegations that Lauren Bobert was indeed
giving constituents tours of the Capitol,
which would be one way that the insurrectionists
would know exactly where to go.
She has denied it, but Democratic Congressman
Steve Cohen was interviewed about it and says
very clearly he saw Lauren Bobert leading
a large group through the Capitol in the days
before the riots.
He can't say these were the insurrectionist.
He's not at a point where he can say that.
But it would at least directly contradict
Lauren Bowerbirds claim that she did no such
thing.
Let's take a look at the video.
That's remarkable.
Remarkable to hear.
I want to ask you about something specific,
because several of your colleagues have alleged
that the rioters may have received inside
help, including including raising the prospect
of tours conducted or with the OK of fellow
sitting members of Congress.
This is quite a charge to make.
Have you seen any hard evidence to substantiate
that allegation?
Only thing that I've seen, Congressman Yarmuth
refresh my recollection yesterday, we saw
Congressman Boehlert taking a group of people
for a tour sometime after the third and before
the six members that they grew up in.
And we saw that she was and she had a large
group with.
Now, whether people are all right.
Was that a large number of people coming to
be with her on this historic occasion and
just wanting to give them the opportunity
to have a tour.
But it was pretty clear that her team is is
that is the team.
She's not on the whole team.
She was with the visitors.
So, Lauren, Bobert is denying this.
And there's a few different things here that
might be going on because there's cameras
everywhere.
There's guest books there.
It is certainly knowable whether Lauren Bobert
was leading a crowd of people, whether it
was an official tour or something else around
the Capitol.
This is information authorities are able to
get.
So why hasn't anyone come out and said, we
have the video, she did do it or we've reviewed
she didn't do it?
Excuse me.
One idea is that the feds, much like they
often do, are waiting for her to make specific.
Claims that are lies before they present her
with the evidence to the contrary, there's
maybe a political aspect to it.
One idea I got an email from someone saying,
you know, maybe the feds are waiting to release
the evidence that Lauren Bobert did this for
the inauguration simply to prevent any even
my nude possibility that Trump would think
to pardon her.
Maybe they're waiting for the evidence to
pile up and for her to lie about it.
But there is no doubt that it is knowable
whether Lauren Bobert and other members of
Congress were giving tours through the Capitol.
And by the way, if it's all recorded, it's
probably knowable whether the people that
she was allegedly giving a tour to were later
involved in the January 6th riots.
So for a ton of this stuff, just in general,
these questions apply to the Trump family
investigations as well.
It makes some sense to wait until after the
inauguration to really scale up the investigations
into Trump organization, criminal and financial
wrongdoing just so that Donald Trump's presidential
power is over.
I as I said earlier, we are going to see the
Trump family hit with many investigations
as well.
But this needs to be figured out.
Lauren Bowerbirds office did not immediately
respond to questions from Talking Points Memo
about, you know, she denies that there was
a tour, but Steve Cohen says he saw her doing
it.
How could both be true?
Do you have a comment?
No comment so far, but if we're looking for
any signal about what may be to come, Lauren
Bowerbirds, communications director, has already
quit now.
I know you're saying she's been in office
a few days, but I mean, yes, Lauren Beaufort's,
communications director has already quit.
Now, in terms of the broader issue of some
of these wacky new members of Congress.
We've got Lauren Bobert.
We have Marjorie Taylor, Green Eye, call her
Kuhnen.
Congresswoman, there's this guy, Madison Cawthorn,
who has talked about having multiple firearms
on him on his wheelchair when he's on the
floor of the House of Representatives.
This is a very bad direction for the country
to be going in.
And my instinct is, when it comes to Bobert
versus Marjorie Taylor Green, I want you to
gut check me on this.
And I tweeted about this over the weekend.
When I see Lauren Bobert, I see someone who
is more of an opportunist and who may go too
far and end up in prison or expelled from
Congress for her antics.
But I see her more as a calculated opportunist.
Marjorie Taylor Green, I see, is an actual
committed kuhnen nut who really has drank
the Kool-Aid.
And I could see her either as a cult member
or even a cult leader, although she doesn't
necessarily seem smart enough to be a cult
leader, doesn't seem manipulative enough to
be a cult leader.
But that's where I see the difference between
Lauren Bobert and Marjorie Taylor Green.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm curious to see where you fall on this.